[Music]
I think I'm gonna call this fine fellow
Friday because I see your John Cena okay
and I raise your Charlie hunt like he
was a biker bad boy on sons of anarchy
but now Charlie's going medieval as King
Arthur
a shirtless Charlie Hunnam and a cameo
by David Beckham just two of the reasons
why we want to see this action-packed
adventure
even if Beck's looks like this thus all
the fuss is about directed by Guy
Ritchie and shot on location throughout
the United Kingdom the centuries-old
legend of King Arthur gets a brand new
spin but no Dragons in this mythical
world instead look out for giant
elephants
85% of this film is about character and
storytelling and then we're going to
just sprinkle some magic on top and blow
the scope way wider as you see behind us
I mean we're on fully realized sets and
you know there's very very little green
screen
Jude Law is King vordigan Arthur's uncle
who wants to keep him from his
birthright as ruler of All England
apparently you know something to turn
he thinks this whippersnapper after this
this peasant can't possibly add or bring
anything to the throne that he hasn't
already considered and answered oh I
like that
Charlie packed on 20 pounds of muscle to
play the part he's wanted since he was a
little kid he carved his own version of
xcalibur out of wood this one's a little
fancier than that we've got seated up a
little bit and given it a sort of a real
tangible power they can slow down time
for the wielder which is of course
incredibly useful if you're moving twice
as fast as your adversaries
you
[Music]